Hi, I'm John Green. Welcome to Crash Course
Big History Project where today we're going
to talk about the Planet of the Apes films. - What's
that? Apparently, those were not documentaries.
But there was an evolutionary process that
saw primates move out of East Africa and transform
the earth into an actual planet of the apes...but
the apes are us.
And then we made the movie and then some prequels
and some sequels and some reboots and now sequels to the reboots.
Man, I can't wait until I get to see the 2018
reboot of this episode of Crash Course Big
History I hear they get James Franco to play
me.
[Theme Music]
So we're about halfway through our series
and after five episodes involving no humans
whatsoever today we are finally gonna get
some people.
Mr. Green, Mr. Green! Why are we already at
humanity, I mean if we're covering 13.8 billion
years shouldn't humanity come in like, the
last two seconds of the last episode? I mean
humans are totally insignificant compared
to the vastness of the universe, like we should
be checking in on how Jupiter's doing.
Fair point, Me From the Past; Jupiter by the
way, still giant and gassy.
There's two reasons why we focus a little
more on humanity in Big History; the selfish
reason is that we care about humans in Big
History because we are humans. We are naturally
curious to figure out where we belong in the huge
sequence of events beginning with the big bang.
Secondly, humans represent a really weird
change in the universe. I mean, so far as we
know, we are one of the most complex things
in the cosmos.
Whether you measure complexity in terms of
biological and cultural building blocks or
networks or connections, I mean, we're kind
of amazing! Now I realize that many of our
viewers will be offended by our human-centric
bias, but humans are amazing. I mean, we invented
the internet and we invented animated GIF
and we invented Dr. Who and then we invented
Tumblr, a place where all of these things
can come together!
So 65 million years ago, catastrophe wiped
out the dinosaurs and we saw the adaptive
radiation of a tiny shrew-like ancestor of
humans that would look more at home like,
next to a hamster wheel than in your family
album. Let's set the stage in the Thought Bubble.
So the slow waltz of plate tectonics continued
to pull Eurasia and the Americas apart expanding
the Atlantic Ocean, primates colonized the Americas,
and separated by the vast Atlantic, continued
their separate evolution into the new world monkeys --
which is not a band name, although it should be.
Then around 45 million years ago, Australia
split from Antarctica and while mammals out-competed
most marsupials in the Americas (except animals
like possums), Australia saw an adaptive radiation
of marsupials. This, of course, meant that
later, one-hundred thousand years ago when
the Americas were having their share of mammoths
and saber-tooth tigers, Australia was having
a spell of gigantic kangaroos, marsupial lions,
and wombats the size of hippos.
Then, somewhere around forty million years
ago, India, which had been floating around
the southern oceans as an island, smashed
into the Eurasian continent with such force
that it created the world's tallest mountain
range, the Himalayas.
Meanwhile, in Africa, Primates continued to
evolve and twenty-five to thirty million years
ago, the line of the apes diverged from theold-world
monkeys and no, neither you, nor a chimp,
is a monkey, nor did we evolve from the monkeys that
are around today - those are like our cousins.
Moreover, we did not evolve from chimpanzees,
the chimpanzee is a cousin as well, not an
uncle. We are not more highly evolved than
they are; Instead, our lines of descent split
off from a common ancestor with chimpanzees
about seven million years ago. Then chimpanzees
further split into a separate species, the
Bonobos. Knowing about this common ancestry
tells us a lot about our shared traits with
other primates.
For instance, we all have fairly large brains,
relative to our body mass, we have our eyes
in the front of our heads from the days when
we hung out in trees and depth perception
was an excellent way of telling how far away
the next tree branch was so as to prevent
us from plummeting to our deaths, and we also
have grasping hands, to make sure, you know,
that you could hold onto the branch in question.
Primates also have hierarchies, social orders
whether male or female led, that determine who gets
primary access to food, mates, and other benefits.
Thanks Thought Bubble! So, our closest evolutionary
cousins, the chimpanzees, can tell us a thing
or two about shared behaviors. For one thing,
while all primates have a hierarchy of alphas
and betas, humans and chimps, who share 98.4%
of their DNA, are the most prone to team up
together and launch a revolution against the
alpha male. We're also both prone to ganging
up, roaming our territory, and beating up
unsuspecting foreigners of the same species,
and not for direct survival reasons.
Chimpanzees have been observed finding a lone
chimp male from another group and kicking,
hitting, and tearing off bits of his body
and then leaving the helpless victim to die
of his wounds, and humans definitely bear
this stamp of our lowly origin, where indeed,
the imperfect step-by-step process of evolution
made us highly intelligent, but still, with
prefrontal cortex's too small, and adrenal
glands maybe too big.
Aggression and blood lust are definitely part
of our shared heritage, and, looking at more
recent human history, does that really surprise
anyone? Contrast that behavior, for a moment,
with the more peaceful Bonobos, who are female-led,
and when a male in her group gets a bit pushy,
the females are prone to gang up and teach
him a lesson. When it comes to inter-group
encounters in the wild, the male Bonobos seem
tense around strangers at first, until usually,
the females from each group cross over and just
have sex with the newcomers, completely diffusing
the tension. Talk about make love, not war
- Bonobos are hippies.
While our common ancestor with chimpanzees
around seven million years ago was more suited
to living in forests and seeking refuge from
danger by climbing trees, climate change in
East Africa made things colder and drier,
and many forests were replaced by woodlands
and wide-open savanna. Life in the savanna
meant our ancestors needed to run from predators
rather than climbing trees, so our line shifted
away from the bow-legged stance reminiscent
of chimpanzees, and developed bipedalism,
where our locomotion came from legs that were
straight and forward-facing.
There's still some debate about when bipedalism
first began, but we know that by the first
australopithecines around four million years
ago, our evolutionary line was bipedal, this
also freed up our hands.
Australopithecines were not very tall, standing
only just above a meter, or just above 3.5
feet, and had brains only a little bigger
than modern chimpanzees. They were largely
herbivores with teeth adapted for grinding
tough fruits and leaves. Australopithecines
may have communicated through gestures and
primitive sounds, but their higher larynx
meant that they couldn't make the range of
sounds required for complex language. There
was probably a lot of pointing and grunting
going on. Kinda like me, before 6 am.
By 2.3 million years ago, homo habilis arrived
on the scene. They weren't much taller than
australopithecines, but they had significantly
larger brains - though still a lot smaller
than later species. Excitingly, homo habilis
is known to have hit flakes off of stones
to use them for cutting. Now, lots of species
use tools, for instance chimpanzees use sticks
for fishing termites out of the ground, they
use rock hammers and leaf sponges and branch
levers and banana leaf umbrellas. A lot of
these skills don't seem to arise spontaneously,
just because of the intelligence of individuals,
but, like in the case of termite fishing,
chimpanzees pass the information on by imitation
- primate see, primate do.
In a way, this social learning is sort of
cultural, yet, succeeding generations of chimpanzees
don't accumulate information, tinker with
it, and improve upon it, so that after 100
years, chimpanzees are owners of highly efficient
and wealthy termite fishing corporations.
Similarly, as impressive as homo habilis stone-working
abilities are, we see very little sign of
technological improvement over the thousands
and thousands of years that habilis existed.
Same goes for homo ergaster erectus, who was
around 1.9 million years ago.
Homo ergaster erectus had an even bigger brain,
was taller, and they even seemed intelligent
and adaptable enough to move into different
environments across the old world. They may
have even begun our first clumsy attempts
at fire, which is vital for cooking meat and
vegetables, opening up opportunities for more
energy and even more brain growth.
But still, there's not much sign of technological
improvement, their tools got the job done,
if it ain't broke, don't fix it.
Yet 1.78 million years ago, we do see homo
ergaster creating a wide new range of teardrop
hand axes in Kenya. By one-point-five 1.5
million years ago, these teardrop axes had
rapidly become common, and had improved in
quality and were shaped with a flat edge into
multi-purpose picks, cleavers, and so forth.
Archaeologists see this as the first possible
sign of tinkering and improvement of technology
that may have been transmitted by social learning. A
faint glimmer of something new. Why is this important?
Well, humans didn't get to where we are
because we're super-geniuses. It's
not like invented the Xbox One out of the
blue one day, it was an improvement upon the
Xbox 360 which was an improvement upon earlier
consoles, arcade machines, computers, and
backward onto the dawn of video games.
In the same way, we didn't just invent our
modern society by sudden inspiration, it's
the result of 250,000 years of tinkering and
improvement. This is where accumulation matters
- it's called collective learning, the ability
of a species to retain more information with
one generation than is lost by the next. This
is what has taken us, in a few thousand years,
from stone tools to rocket engines to being
able to have the Crash Course theme song as
your ringtone. Progress!
If there was collective learning in homo ergaster,
it was very slow and very slight. This may
have been due to limitations on communication,
abstract thought, group size, or just plain
brain power. But over the next two million
years, things started to pick up. Homo antecessor,
Homo Heidelbergensis and the Neanderthals
developed the first systematically controlled
use of fire in hearths, the first blade tools,
the earliest wooden spears, the earliest use
of composite tools, where stone was fastened
to wood, all before homo sapiens were ever
heard of, around 250,000 years ago.
Neanderthals even moved into colder climates,
where they were compelled to invent clothing,
they used complex tool-manufacture to produce
sharp points and scrapers and hand-axes and
wood handles, and they improved their craft
over time.
While evolution by natural selection is a
sort of learning mechanism that allows a species
to adapt generation after generation, with
a lot of trial and error, and death - collective
learning allows for tinkering, adaptation,
and improvement on a much faster scale with
each generation and across generations without
waiting for your genes to catch up.
Anatomically similar homo sapiens have been
around for about 250,000 years, and throughout
that time, we've been expanding our toolkit
from stone tools to shell fishing to trade
and actual fishing, mining, and by 40,000
years ago we had art, including cave images,
decorative beads and other forms of jewelry,
and even the world's oldest known musical
instruments - flutes carved from mammoth ivory
and bird bones.
All this stuff came about as a result of collective
learning. As long as you have a population
of potential innovators, who can keep dreaming
up new ideas and remembering old ones and an
opportunity for those old innovators to pass
their ideas onto others, you're likely to
have some technological progress.
These mechanisms are still working today - we've
got over seven billion potential innovators on
this planet, and almost instantaneous communication,
allowing us to do so many marvelous things
including teach you about Big History on the
internet.
So life for early humans was pretty good,
like foraging didn't require particularly
long hours - the average work day for a forager
was about 6.5 hours. When you compare that
to an average of 9.5 hours for a peasant farmer
in medieval Europe, or the average of nine
hours for a typical office worker today, foraging
seems downright leisurely.
Quick aside: I work thirty minutes a day less
than a peasant farmer in medieval Europe?
That's not progress! Stan, I want more time
off!
Stan just pointed out that I have a chair,
something that peasant farmers in medieval
Europe did not enjoy, and I want to say that
I'm very grateful for my chair.
Thank you for my chair, Stan.
Anyway, a forager would go out, hunt or gather,
come home, eat, spend time with the family,
dance, sing, tell stories, and foragers were
also always on the move, which made it less
likely that they'd contaminate their water,
or sit around waiting for a plague to develop.
And with their constant walking and their
varied diet, foragers were in many ways healthier
than the peasants of ancient civilizations.
There were also, in some ways, healthier than
us, but we have antibiotics for now, so we
live longer, for now.
The classic view of foraging life is best
described by Thomas Hobbes, who wrote:
"No arts, no letters, no society, and which
is worst of all continual fear and danger
of violent death and the life of man, solitary,
poor, nasty, brutish, and short."
Except, not really. I mean, life for the average
person in twelfth century France was also
a smidge nasty, brutish, and short, and the
lack of wealth disparity in foraging cultures
may imply greater equality between social
rankings and even between the genders since
female gatherers appear to be responsible
for the majority of food collected, rather
than the hunting males. And from that perspective,
life was kind of ruined by the advent of agriculture
and then, later, with states, as Jean-Jacques
Rousseau said,
"The first person, who having enclosed a plot
of land, took it into his head to say, 'this
is mine' and found people simple enough to
believe him, was the true founder of civil
society. What crimes, wars, murders, what
miseries and horrors would the human race
have spared, had someone pulled up the stakes
or filled in the ditch and cried out to his
fellow men: 'do not listen to this imposter,
you are lost if you forget that the fruits of the
Earth belong to all, and the Earth to no one'"
and thus summarizes one of the great debates
in the world of political science. Man, Big
History discusses everything! Now, it's possible
that neither Rousseau nor Hobbes was completely
correct, and that, like, private property and agriculture
didn't create the glory days or end them.
Like, as previous mentioned, all primates
have a dominance hierarchy of some kind. Also,
you don't need a wealth disparity to drive
human beings to hurt each other - like, surveys
of excavated remains from the paleolithic
indicate a murder rate that was possibly as
high as ten percent. Now, those statistics
are still disputed, but despite the relatively
short work day, life in the paleolithic sounds
a lot less appealing when you consider the
high murder rate, and also, the occasional
infanticide. That's not even to mention the
old or disabled people who, when they couldn't
keep up anymore, were abandoned to die in
the wild. I can't help but feel that I might
not have thrived in the paleolithic what with
my visual impairment and general lack of interest
in hunting.
Anyway, we call this the Hobbes vs. Rousseau
debate, and it's still unresolved. I mean,
humans may have been corrupted in many ways
by society, on the other hand, it's possible
a lot of the crimes and follies of human history
may just be symptoms of our coping with the
bad wiring left to us by evolution.
You know, humans are a bit of an obsolete
machine, we aren't particularly well-suited
to the many lifestyle changes that have happened
in the past few thousand years - faster than
our genes can keep pace with. But how you
interpret the lives of early human foragers
largely determines your view of history and
also the fundamental nature of the human character.
Ask yourself which side you sit on: Is humanity
fundamentally good and corrupted by technology
and modern social orders, or are we fundamentally
flawed and in need of some sort of structure
and authority? Or is there some kind of both/and way
of addressing the question? Here at Crash Course,
we don't have answers, but we are grateful that
you're pondering these questions with us.
In any case, collective learning was really
good for our survival, but then, 74,000 years
ago, disaster struck. A super-eruption at
Mt. Toba on the island of Sumatra in present-day
Indonesia clouded the skies with ash and cooled
the climate. Plants and animals, a.k.a. food, died
off and genetics studies showed that this
reduced the human population to a few thousand
people. So as a result of this, we aren't
exactly inbred, but there's more genetic diversity
between two of the major groups of chimpanzees
in Africa than there is in all of humanity.
So this small group heroically recovered and
spread out of Africa 64,000 years ago, colonizing
diverse environments and continuing to innovate.
For 13.8 billion years since the beginning
of the universe, complexity had been rising
in a powerful crescendo, but in the space
of a few millennia, collective learning was
about to make things really bonkers.
More on that next time.